[Music]
tonight is a talk where we're we're
honored to have a a speaker who is part
of the fellow fellowship program
actually at Stanford's casbahs the
Center for Advanced Study in the
behavioral sciences we've had a
fantastic ongoing partnership with
casbahs this is I believe the third
casbahs speaker so far this year and
we're we're just really thrilled matter
if I could have a former speaker from
earlier in the year in the house good to
see you Chris
and I think we have some brochures out
for casbahs it's it's a fantastic
program that's been going on at in Palo
Alto since the the middle of the last
century and really some of the finest
social scientists are there every year
they have their own set of programs and
and media from past talks people like
Daniel Kahneman actually Ruth Bader
Ginsburg was a former casbahs fellow so
we thank them for the great partnership
that this has been and encourage you to
check them out because they've got
things you might be interested in as
well
tonight speaker you know this is an area
and where the the history it's it's it's
such an interesting place because
Elizabeth is going to be talking about
her work with chimpanzees and other apes
and and yet it's also work on humans and
we will find that this area that is is
is studying these creatures there's so
much that we learn about ourselves and
it's really a crossroads from
evolutionary biology to anthropology and
archeology
there there are so many different areas
that are crossing their paths and
adjacent to the work that she does
Elizabeth lonsdorf is a primatologist
she's associate professor of psychology
and biological foundations of behavior
at Franklin and Marshall College she's
now in her 20th year of working at Gombe
National Park in Tanzania and we are
just thrilled to have her here a big
round of applause for Elizabeth rondure
thank you Michael for that great
introduction I'm not good at managing
multiple devices so just bear with me is
that as I get used to things here I'm
really excited to be here as part of
this partnership between long now and
caspase it's been a fantastic year for
me and a lot of my fellow fellows are in
the audience here and the fact that it's
the end of April means we have to leave
soon which makes me very sad but I'm
glad to have this be kind of a final
event of my time here and talk to you
about kind of the long-term approach
that we are taking to study development
and and how apes grow up in our closest
living relatives and those animals are
of course the chimpanzee here on your
left and the gorilla here on your right
so first I want to make sure that we're
all on board with who the five great ape
species are I'm just gonna be talking
about two of them tonight in the context
of the fifth but so on your top left
there you've got the orangutan of
Southeast Asia I'm not gonna be talking
about tonight but they are in this group
of our primate family on the top right
you have gorillas we'll be talking about
them tonight on the bottom left and
right you have the two animals that are
most closely related to us in the world
that is the chimpanzee on the left and
the bonobo on the right so the bonobo is
a very chimpanzee like animal but very
different and we can we can talk about
that if you want the fifth-grade ape is
of course shown here and it's most full
and beautiful state of Kate and Leo and
the Titanic my husband's rolling his
eyes like I cannot believe you managed
to get Leo and yet another talk
so these are afraid of great ape species
this is your primate family and we're
going to talk about the linkages between
them tonight okay so my story starts
with these three women that have been
now come to be known the Tri mates
little play on words there who are
really we're kind of the the parents the
mothers of the long-term study of our
closest living relatives the great apes
we have Dian Fossey who studied gorillas
of course Jane Goodall studying
chimpanzees and Baruti galdikas who
studies orangutans and they come from
one single parentage line and his name
is Louis Leakey that is their academic
father and you can see him here with a
very young Jane Goodall so Louis was a
paleoanthropologist he was famous for
being very bombastic and kind of
operating outside the normal realms of
how his science worked at the time he
had this crazy idea that we would find
the origins of modern humans in Africa
which we did he also had this crazy idea
that behavior doesn't fossilize which it
doesn't and so that we should look to
our closest living relatives in the
animal kingdom if we wanted to
understand the human the evolution of
human behavior so he had this other
crazy idea to send women out into the
wilds of Africa to watch great apes he
had a variety of reasons for thinking
that women would do this better than men
and we can talk about that afterwards if
you would like so Jane went saved up all
her money from her secretary job she
went to Kenya with that money because
she always loved animals and kind of
stormed into Louis Leakey's office in
the National Museums of Kenya and said I
would like to you know do something with
animals and he said great you're going
to Tanzania that's like pretty much
literally what happened and the British
government said slow your roll there
Louis we are not sending a young 26 year
old blonde woman to Tanzania to study
apes without an escort
and by escort they of course meant a man
right they didn't want her to go without
a man to protect her and she said okay
great I'll take an escort and she took
her mother
van so this is van Goodall up on her
left on the beach at Gombe and then in
her tent and so van and jean is who set
up the study of chimpanzees at Gombe for
the first two years so Jane was walking
into a place where the chimpanzees were
very scared of humans they had been
hunted they were not comfortable with
her being in their presence so she did a
very kind of at the time thought to be
kind of a crazy thing she just went to
this place called Jane's peak and every
day she sat in the same clothes with the
same equipment and was very just still
and watched them across the valley and
stayed very consistent very predictable
until the chimps kind of lost their fear
from far away and then she subsequently
over many years was able to get them to
lose their fear from very close up Jane
you know much like her mentor Louis
there were kind of two things about her
she was very bold and brave and kind of
wanted to do things her own way she also
didn't have any formal college education
she had only gone to secretary or school
so she decided like oh the best way to
get to understand these animals is to
study them as individuals
I'd like to learn who they are I'd like
to know their personalities I'd like to
learn about who their friends are their
emotions and she did crazy things like
giving them names instead of using
numbers to identify them and the
scientific establishment at the time was
like that's really cute sweetie but like
that's not the way we do things and now
here we are 60 years later in the Gumby
study is still going strong as I'm
evidence of standing in front of you so
what Jane really changed in the in the
field of studying animal behavior was
making it okay eventually to think about
these animals in terms of being
individuals with individual personal
relationships friendships personalities
emotions and really conducting close
observation of individuals and their
individual stories that's what was
really different about Jane's study with
the chimps now Jane was one of these try
mates as I mentioned before and what's
really interesting about these three is
they really did operate kind of like
sibling
so this is kind of a story you have to
dig dig to find out but Jane was very
much the older sibling like the
responsible you know one Diane has been
reported to be the kind of the jealous
middle sibling and brute a was like the
happy baby who's just happy to be there
with everybody and so the Lois kind of
set up this system where after Jane's
study became a success and he met Diane
and Diane very similar to Jane walked up
to him and said I want to do what she
did but with a different animal
he had this proving ground for Diane and
then Baruti and what he did was he would
first send them to Van Goodall in London
they would have to stay with van for
several weeks until she determined that
they were okay and then he would send
them to Jane and Gombe so she could
field test them and make sure they were
okay now nobody knows never revealed
what these metrics were so we don't know
but at any rate Diane passed the test
and ended up as I'll cover later at Kara
Sookie what's interesting about Diana's
is like Jane she always had more of an
affinity for animals growing up than the
normal girl she actually got along with
animals quite much more than she did
with people she had a difficult
childhood and she was desperate to be a
veterinarian but she was really bad at
chemistry and physics so instead she
became an occupational therapist with
children so he was actually fully
fledged in her career when she saw Louis
Leakey give a talk and walked up to him
afterwards and said that's what I want
to do and so in 1967 Jane started Gombe
in 1960 Diane went out in 1967 to Rwanda
and started the karisoke a research
center and the long-term study of
mountain gorillas there she did take a
page out of Jane's book and really think
about studying these animals as
individuals with individual stories and
histories and and aspects to them
she habituated the animals to her
presence much less like Jane did and she
did end up forging a very close
relationship with a particular animal at
a particular gorilla named digit and
that's digit they're looking at her
field know
with her digit you know they really
really accepted Diane into their into
their community they're the gorillas and
so she forged this very strong bond with
digits she has written about this as he
was like her true best friend and he
really greased the wheels with the other
gorillas like he accepted her and the
other girl is really good okay she must
be alright
so digit really paved her way here and
this was a friendship that would last
all of digits life this picture was
taken ten years later digits a fully
grown adult gorilla who would seem to be
quite terrifying to sit next to but they
were they were very close friends until
his death now his death is what changed
Diane's life forever
so Diane in the morning in 1977 got a
report that poachers were in her area in
Rwanda she went out to check her groups
and she found digit with his head in his
hands removed so she went did a full 180
at that point from behavioral research
and went 100% into anti poaching and
protection of the gorillas in her area
and her methods for doing this were
quite unorthodox they were outside of
what we would envision as any you know
kind of standardized conservation
practices that we would do today
she really chased she basically chased
after the poachers with like a knife and
chased them off and so her her her
anti-poaching efforts brought a lot of
anger to the poaching community and in
1985 she was killed in her research camp
in a crime that has never been solved so
she is buried next to her best friend
digit you can actually visit her grave
site in Rwanda so Diane's personal story
is over but there is a legacy of both
these women that I just want to touch on
before I launch into what I specifically
work on Jane is very much with us she's
very much alive and well she has more
energy than all of us in this room her
legacy is very strong this picture in
the middle is taken of a group of either
current or former researchers at Gombe
taken about two years ago
Oh Jane let me see if I can work this
thing Jane's here in the middle I'm over
here so this was taken about two years
ago and then around you you see where we
put a lot of focus in the last couple
decades is bringing into the formal
research training our Tanzanian
counterparts in Tanzania and there's
several of our Tanzanian PhDs and and
veterans a veterinary medicine they're
the Dian Fossey legacy
despite her passing many years ago now
is also quite strong an incredible
presence in Rwanda working very
cooperatively with the government in
terms of both behavioral research and
anti poaching and Diane's legacy of
especially involving women in field
research is clear there as you look at
the pictures around the around the edges
ok so now I'm going to launch into more
of the the sciency stuff that's that's
the background storytelling bit and I
want to give you a quick crash course in
these two great apes especially in terms
of their social organization and how
it's a bit different between the two
species so chimpanzees over here on the
Left have what's called a fission fusion
social structure and that sounds a
little bit confusing but it's basically
our social structure right you wake up
in the morning you're with your most
most closely bonded bond partner you go
maybe to the gym or the coffee shop
that's a different part of your
community a different group of
individuals you go to work that's a
different part of your community so
you're fusing with certain groups and
visioning from them throughout the day
so whoever you're with during the day
changes on a minute-to-minute hourly
basis that's the chimpanzee social
structure so at any given moment your
target chimpanzee that you're taking
behavioural data on could be alone or
could be with 40 other individuals in
the gorillas it's quite different
because they're a very cohesive tight
social group headed by the silverback
male which you can see there in that
photo
so the typical gorilla social structure
is that silverback male he's usually got
three or four wives and all their kids
and that's a tight cohesive social group
that spends all day every day together
okay so in a gorilla community all the
babies of that group belong to that
silverback
in a chimpanzee community the mating
system is promiscuous anybody could be
the dad of that baby okay
so those are some important differences
to keep in mind so the story I'm going
to tell you today is really about a new
study that my collaborators and I are
embarking on to better understand ape
life history so life history is just the
series of variables that describe kind
of a life cycle of an animal we have
these very everybody can can be kind of
reduced down to these variables and so
I'll give you an example of the numbers
for these variables when it comes to
chimpanzees so gestation length about 8
months kind of like us agit weaning this
is what's the one that's going to be
important for this talk anywhere from
four to seven years okay interbirth
interval kind of maps on that it's about
three to five years that's the interval
between babies age at first reproduction
about twelve to fourteen for females and
female chimpanzees litter size in this
case is one you have one baby at a time
typically you know a meerkat or whatever
is gonna have a whole bunch more the
maximum lifespan for female chimpanzees
somewhere around fifty for males
somewhere around forty five okay so
that's the scope of variables that we're
working within so human babies are quite
different then the babies of our closest
living relative in the animal kingdom
and our life history characteristics are
very different so we have really big
neonates really big infants relative to
our body size and they have really big
heads okay this is a great example and I
don't feel bad disparaging that baby
because it's mine so
he's a really big head he's ten now it's
kind of evened out a little bit but
what's interesting is that typically
when an animal has very large neonates
like an elephant or a whale it means
that the investment that maternal
investment in that baby is so large that
the the interbirth interval is very
extended right so if you have a very big
baby that's a very expensive baby not
just in terms of money and that means
you have to have a longer time between
your babies what humans do that's a
little different is we have an earlier
age at weaning than would be expected by
the size of our babies we weaned on
average at about two years if you're
looking across culturally and we have a
short interbirth interval so somehow
humans have ramped up investment in
these really big expensive babies but
also ramped up fertility and shorten the
interbirth interval okay we have really
prolonged growth during childhood kids
take forever to grow up and I feeling
that today because of something that
happened at school we have a relatively
later age at first birth thank God and
we have a relatively longer life span so
these are kind of unique characteristics
of human life history and essentially we
think that those are tied to some very
unique aspects of human behavior so
because we have really big brains that
doesn't necessarily that doesn't map
directly onto intelligence but it has to
do with complexity and especially in the
case of humans we think it has to do
with social complexity so I talked to
you about chimp social structure and
gorilla social structure humans have
really amped up sociality I mean I'm
talking to a whole bunch of you like
we're friends and apes not going to do
that right so that kind of that kind of
open sociality with strangers that's a
that's a uniquely human characteristic
ultra cooperation I'm saying ultra
because five apes are never gonna help
you push your car out of the snow right
it's not gonna happen but five strangers
will right so these are things that you
we just don't see in the animal kingdom
this kind of intensive sociology this
helping out of strangers we just don't
see it
tied to that we think are the intense
kind of complexity of the social customs
and norms we've developed as humans that
goes along with laws and ethics and then
we have very complex outcroppings of
what we call our cumulative culture so
we have cultural differences that we
build on and our culture advances at a
dizzying rate compared to other animals
in the animal kingdom okay so this is
what's what's kind of neat about us and
what the project that I'm going to tell
you about tonight is trying to deal with
this kind of how did we get here and and
is part of the roadmap of how we got
here how we got to be so weird
as humans is it have to do with these
changes in development we see in terms
of these really large expensive babies
that we somehow managed to produce more
quickly with an accelerated weaning
process okay
so we don't actually know what was going
on in our hominid ancestors and you know
in order to reconstruct that the best
thing we can do at this time is to know
what's going on in our closest living
relatives but we actually know really
small amounts about weaning in great
apes we've know virtually nothing about
weaning in great apes so that's that's
the kind of life history character I'm
gonna focus on tonight to talk to you
about alright so this is a there's a new
project that's you know under a year old
and we're kind of integrating the long
term approach of Jane and Diane and data
collection with some new technologies to
really try and get at the in various
ways weaning and mountain gorillas and
chimpanzees the two animals that are
most like us that are most likely some
sort of representative for where we came
from okay
this is in partnership with many many
people but in the Jane Goodall Institute
the Fauci Fund Max Planck Institute my
institution Franklin and Marshall
College and George Washington University
and we've got cute baby apes there so
that's always good okay so the first
thing we aim to do in this project is to
really well characterize those dietary
transitions from exclusively feeding on
Mother's Milk
to that transition to solid food and we
know that that it's a process not not a
hard line and the way we have done this
up to this point is by doing behavioral
observations by watching these Apes for
years and years and years and
documenting when they're suckling at
their mother's breast and when they
start feeding on solid food now remember
I mentioned to you that weaning and Apes
takes four to seven years it's a really
long period of time and of course
they're eating solid food well before
seven years old and so what we want to
do in this project is really narrow that
window or understand that window much
better and so in addition to this
behavioral approach of really analyzing
our long-term data for suckling behavior
and eating solid foods what we're doing
is collecting a lot of a poop okay a
poop is gold in my world like you can
find out so many things from a poop you
have no idea how stressed they are what
diseases they have like what they ate
yesterday it's amazing one of the newer
things you can find out from a poop as
if you analyzed the stable isotopes in
that poop you can actually figure out
what trophic level an infant is relative
to its mother so you can measure stable
isotopes of nitrogen and essentially if
the kid is enriched in nitrogen relative
to the mother that means that that kid
is still a trophic level above the mom
ie I'm still eating mom I'm still
feeding primarily on mom right and when
the levels of nitrogen come down to the
same as mom you know that the
contribution of mother's milk to the
diet has leveled off and they're eating
surviving primarily on solid food so
this has been done in one study in great
apes by yuliya Buddhist GU and this is
don't worry about what the graph is
saying all that much what's important is
that horizontal line is infant age in
months and anything above the line is
when the kid is eating mom and anything
on the line is when the kid is not and
what this graph tells you is that around
25 to 30 months old the kid looks just
like the mom the kid is no longer eating
mom at that point that's less than a
three-year-old and remember I told you
that weaning occurs but
four and seven so they're nutritionally
independent a mom well before they stop
weaning which is kind of weird right so
we want to narrow that window a little
bit more understand that a little bit
better get more data from chimps and
also from gorillas because that type of
work has never been done in gorillas the
second thing we want to do is figure out
that huge window four to seven years old
what are the sources of variation in
there there's various theory that would
suggest that that might change depending
on maternal age whether mom is large
body size or in better body condition
there's some theory that suggests that
infants have to reach a particular size
themselves to be weaned so infant size
for age birth order maybe firstborn kids
are different than the second-born kids
maybe infant sex matters we just have no
idea what could contribute to this big
variation that we see so a lot of these
variables we can understand from our
long-term records right maternal age we
knew these moms are we know when they
were born we know how old they are but
and I should say I say that like it's
really simple it's only because these
studies have been going on more than 50
years okay so let me let me really point
that out there
that's why we know that we know the
birth order we know the infant sex
obviously but we don't have or we didn't
have until recently a good non-invasive
way to study size in wild animals
attempt to measure a wild chimpanzee or
gorilla will fail if you ask them to
step on a scale or hold up a ruler I
mean you might not get the ruler or your
arm back so we've had to develop ways
that that do this without disturbing
them and what's come out of some
research actually on horses and other a
mammal z-- is this approach of a
parallel laser photogrammetry
so essentially you build this box here
on the left which that's the exact box I
just built in December you try to get it
through airport security all the way to
Tanzania which was surprisingly easy
and what that does is it
it's a series of it's a laser beam split
by two prisms and they're perfectly
parallel all the time and because
they're perfectly parallel all the time
they're always exactly 4 centimeters
apart so you take that to the field
you give your collaborators the box they
put it on a camera they pointed at a
chimp and now you have a scale you're
projecting something exactly 4
centimeters apart onto a wild animal you
can use that as a scale to measure body
size ok that's that's that our little
scale blown up because those dots are
pretty hard to see this doesn't bother
them these chimpanzees are used to weird
people pointing weird stuff at them all
the time because the studies been going
on 60 years so this doesn't bother them
so again we're doing this in both
gorillas and chimpanzees to try and suss
out some of these sources of variation
NewTek with long term data ok now we get
to some cool stuff which is outside my
direct area of expertise but I've had to
learn a lot putting this project
together because coming from the
perspective of behavior I always was
like why do people care about bones like
behaviors where the interesting stuff is
right totally wrong so what we're doing
here is we're really trying to speak to
the anthropological record and try and
understand how dental proxies of weaning
line up with those behavioral and
physiological proxies that I just
introduced to you so we're really using
a variety of measures on teeth to
understand the weaning history of in
known individuals with known suckling
histories ok so I'm going to talk about
a molar for a second so the first molar
m1 is associated in many many primates
the emergence of that molar with weaning
it's it's seen as a good dental proxy of
weaning and in a variety of living
primates and it's often used when you're
talking about hominid samples to infer
weaning in our human ancestors who's
whose skeletons have been have been dug
up from paleo anthropological
investigations so those are from
deceased animals another way that you
can study molar emergence
and kind of more fun in my perspective
is to study it in living animals and how
do you do this you go out and you follow
around baby chimpanzees and gorillas and
when they laugh which they do a lot when
they're playing you take pictures of
their open mouths right this is like the
best job ever right you fall around baby
chimpanzees way for them to laugh take a
picture and you can see here there's
there's a chimpanzee laughing there on
the left this is the work of my
colleague serene mashanda here on the
right and you can actually see if you've
got good enough pictures when that first
molar starts to emerge in living Apes
with documented suckling histories okay
so this isn't the case of we just have
the bones we have the bones and the
behavior in living animals and it turns
out that chimps and gorillas have a very
different are very different in terms of
how much suckling and m-1 emergence
matches up gorillas here on the bottom
mountain gorillas weaning is about at 3
& 1 emergence is about at 3 so they
match up really tightly chimpanzees
which are more like us in terms of our
evolutionary history it's a total
disconnect m1 emergence is at about
three years and weaning is somewhere
around five years they're not matched up
at all so what does this mean for when
we dig hominid ancestors you know out of
the ground is that really a good proxy
for weaning we don't we're not sure and
we hope to find out through this
research okay the other thing though
about teeth that's really cool is that
tooth enamel is an incremental tissue
meaning it's laid down and with a
particular periodicity and if you have
accumulated skeletons because you're
lucky enough to work at a site where
data has been collected for 50 or 60
years they also click skeletons of
deceased individuals you can analyze
those teeth for a whole bunch of stuff
that's hiding in their enamel so you get
it this is a gorilla tooth you get a
tooth you embed it in a matrix you start
taking thin sections of it and you start
throwing it under a microscope okay
so when you're looking at this
microscope what's really nice is
basically that the ridges and the dental
enamel are like a clock
the long lines the kind of ones going
like this the striae of retzius they're
laid down pretty much on a weekly basis
and the little cross hatches are laid
down on a daily basis so you have a
clock that can account for the
day-to-day development of that
individual in their enamel all you need
is time zero and very nicely there is a
time zero there's a neonatal line so you
know times zero you know how many weeks
and days have been laid down before any
event including social stressors and a
stress like weaning okay so you can't
see these at the top I'm gonna blow them
up what happens is that when there's
defects in the Amana enamel when there's
perturbations that were that pattern
gets messed up that means that something
has happened that's stressful
or a change in that animal these are
those perturbations blown up you can see
it week 57 at week 71 and at week 85
something stressful happened in this
animal you go back to the behavioral
records you can understand what that is
and then weaning has a very distinct
signal as well so this this clock
embedded in the dental enamel is really
allowing us to get a really precise
timeline of weaning in these individuals
whereas before we're just watching it
whether they're suckling or not okay now
here's the zoo the coolest kind of last
bit and this is chemistry so if there's
chemists in the audience I'm sorry this
is this is not a gorilla or chimp tooth
this is a macaque tooth there on the
right so this is serial sampling of the
enamel from a macaque tooth another
another primate and what happens as that
enamel is laid down is that the chemical
composition changes based on what
they're eating so let me get my little
pointer out again so here this is the
prenatal period it's all green and blue
because that's low barium because that's
the maternal diet so that's just the
food coming across the placental barrier
it's the same chemical composition as
what the mom is eating basically then
here's birth this first dotted line and
everything here
red and orange and yellow is enriched in
barium breast milk is super high and
it's barium two calcium concentration
that is actually observable in the
sampling of the enamel and then here you
can see this transitional this this
represents a transitional feeding to
solid food and then this is totally
solid food here so we can look at the
chemical composition to say precisely
when the maternal milk contribution
starts to decline and map that onto our
clock from the histology which is super
cool right especially me as a
behaviorist I'm like yeah well they
stopped suckling at 7:00 and they're
like yeah but they've been eating solid
food for four years like what is
happening in that timeframe so to wrap
up some ups this is a new project just
kind of just just launched this year but
we're going from behavioral observations
of suckling and live apes that's all we
know about weaning essentially we're
collecting a lot of poop we're going to
figure out the physiological indicators
of weaning we're going to use kind of
new photographic techniques to
understand the variation and what might
be causing some of the variation and
weaning that we see we're going to
overlay with all that data evidence from
the dental record and in this case we
can add a chemical analysis of enamel as
well to get an even more precise
timeline of weaning and we can actually
with super cool because of Jane and
Diane's work is that we can do that in
individuals with documented suckling
data from 40 years ago so it's a real
kind of incredible compilation of being
able to take this long-term behavioral
data and overlay it with new techniques
to understand a really critical life
history characteristic and our closest
living relatives
so to sum up what we're trying to do is
figure out how we got to these big
expensive babies that we somehow ramped
up production of by weaning them earlier
relative to the great apes and to in
order to inform what might have been
going on in our hominid ancestors but
the way that we can address that at the
moment is with living apes so that's the
kind of question mark that we're
attempting to take away with this
project and
and the kind of bigger moral of the
story is that like when you take
long-term data and you overlay some new
techniques in isotope ecology and in
photogrammetry you can answer questions
that could never be answered before and
I can't say like how incredibly grateful
and gratifying it is to work at a site
that has been going on 60 years like
Gombe and in the case of the site and I
in site in Rwanda over 50 years we just
wouldn't be able to do this unless they
had continued the studies for decades
and whenever I talk to people they're
like oh god chimpanzees I mean don't we
know everything yet like Jane was there
and what 1960 and I'm like no because
now we can do chemistry on tooth enamel
and we can do all this cool new stuff so
it just it lays the groundwork for
really an endless series of
investigation as the new technology
develops so with that I can't stop
without acknowledging that this is the
work of very very many people might
direct collaborators on this project are
listed here along with the agencies that
support us in Tanzania and the US and
then in particular in that Jane Goodall
Institute the site where I focus most of
my work these incredible people that are
there on the ground every day collecting
this data and then the funders that have
supported this project in particular the
National Science Foundation as the
current grant we're working under so
with that I'm going to stop I'm going to
get my cocktail and then answer question
questions thank you thank you
thank you so much where do you want to
be why don't you have sin on that side
and and although we will get you a
beverage directly I'm gonna I'm gonna
start you off with a couple questions
and we'll have questions from you so
please start thinking about your
questions love a mic going around I want
to ask a couple just sort of details to
make sure I understand things there
because I know less about teeth than you
do and I'm excited to learn more
actually the first one was so you talked
about their nutritionally independent
from their mothers but they haven't
weaned yet yeah so they're still nursing
they're still doing something uh-huh
I mean it could be they just like having
their mouth there it's comforting four
ways to play is the official cocktail
like tonight's talk five ways to play
yes that's what we're trying to figure
out I mean if they're so we know that
orphans who who lose their mother at
about age four about fifty percent of
the time they make it and and the
thought there is that those that don't
have not fully weaned and that there's
variation in that weaning process but
yeah it looks like the maternal
contribution of milk ends it's somewhere
around two to three years and yet
sometimes they suckle for this
incredibly long time so is that because
we're seeing the tail ends of the
distribution the variation is that just
or that is that individual who's
suckling until seven really still
getting most of their nutrition from the
milk we don't know that's what we're
trying to figure out is how much of this
is really a physiological need versus
kind of a behavioral comfort behavior
and and so the the data on that that
you're getting from the teeth lined up
with the poop data from earlier for that
on the teeth stuff and this is my pure
ignorance on on how work but but how
long those those lines that are being
laid down that's happening through
development or through their entire life
what's can you can you explain how that
works okay yeah and it actually happens
it actually happens in utero so you can
see birth I mean that neonatal line is
at birth right and then the enamel gets
laid down with it but that the m1 that
molar one is there in the fetus I mean
it's already there right so we can we
can time things from prenatal times
throughout life well the problem is with
the old ones their teeth fall out and
then we don't have as many teeth from
them so we do have such a full access to
them we have some skeletons actually
once we since we started doing this that
we've that we brought out of the
archives that had only two or three
teeth left
so yeah part of the aging process or
some sort of dental disease that we can
think of but like our very old males
that live till you know late 40s 50s in
there you can tell they're old by their
teeth I mean they don't have dental care
like they don't have a dental plan and
so if something has happened and it
affects the teeth it it goes through the
whole jaw line and and so you're you're
doing this work now with a a teeth
expert what's his actual her her sorry
of course I should have known because
primatology what's what's her her
expertise is Oh her expertise is in this
hard tissue biology so understanding
reading the teeth that's her expertise
this is my colleague at George
Washington University and so we kind of
came up with this project because I was
really interested in the behavioral
aspects of infant development and
weaning and she was like well you know
there's all these new things we can do
with teeth and then we said okay well
what can we do a living apes and we
found this stuff we could do with the
poop and then put it all together and I
think it just sort of emphasizes that
this work you're doing because of its
connection with human evolutionary
biology and and all that and the fossil
work that's been done as well you really
it seems like you're at this sort of
crossroads of different disciplines and
in fact we you were saying you're based
in psychology department there's a lot
of range and we're primatology just
actually sitting there then can you just
tell us a little bit
primary primatologists are weird because
depending on your particular question
that you like to ask you might sit in a
psychology department if it's a question
about cognition you might sit in a
biology department if it's if it's a
question about evolution phylogeny
taxonomy you might sit in anthropology
department if you're interested in you
know evolutionarily ancient hominids and
how primates are a model for that so
what's fun for me is that I kind of like
all of those questions and so I've been
able to develop projects where I get to
collaborate with people that do that
stuff so I can sit kind of in my my
comfort zone relative to my area of
expertise but then I get to learn about
how to read teeth and we have a question
thanks everybody who's watching on the
livestream long no members are watching
us everywhere now hopefully and we had a
question which is a great question there
it has been these these prominent names
are all female researchers and is that
what do you attribute that to or what
sort of the history of that of beyond
the the Tri mates does that continue
beyond the trimester well it actually
comes somewhat from the history of the
Tri mates so the story goes that Louis
Leakey when he decided to send Jane out
as an untrained secretary who'd had no
formal education in fact she never got a
bachelor's degree she went straight for
a PhD he thought an untrained scientist
would be better able to observe apes
without bias
he thought that education would cloud
their their thinking because at the time
animal behavior was really not open to
the idea of animals having really
complex individual agency over their
behavior it was more kind of a pigeon in
a skinner box kind of thing so he
thought take away all that training I
want somebody who will just sit and
observe quietly and then the sit and it
was a quietly part he said that he
thought women would do that better they
the other side of that story is he liked
being around you
beautiful women so I think it's
somewhere probably a little bit of both
those those three women did not fail him
and you know setting the stage for
decade along studies of apes that have
been incredibly successful so I've got
another question about them first I want
to point out Joe there's Joe
he's got the mic in the audience so get
his attention he's going to be lining up
the questions after if I ask you this
one more but but look for him and we'll
get your questions too
so it's this amazing you have these
these three researchers who are each not
coming from a traditional scientific
research back where the woman who
studies a ranch hands came trained as a
biologist interested in animals but Jane
and Diane certainly did not so so
clearly it it worked they had great
ideas I'm curious to the extent that you
know were they coordinating were they
kind of doing parallel kind of
techniques with the different
populations and and is that or what
other things to say you know what's kind
of shocking for me to report about this
project is that this is the first real
scientific collaboration using the
behavioral data between the Jane site
and the Dian site which is interesting
giving their history as academic
siblings and the fact that Diane modeled
a lot of the way that she did things
although Jane but I mean if you think
about it like there wasn't email I mean
one was in Tanzania and one was in
Rwanda how much are you gonna coordinate
and they're fighting off poachers and
they're fighting malaria I mean it
wasn't as easy to do collaborative
science I think as it is today and then
of course you know Jane wrote her big
book this tome that we call the Gombe
Bible in 1986 and Diane had already been
killed so I think it took so long to
amass data to look at the long-term
perspective and then Diane was already
gone
by that point you have a question back
there great presentation and amazing
work you guys doing girls doing I just
wanted to clarify a few things and if I
understand correctly from your
presentation the
ages around I mean time is around let's
say six years right four to six yeah so
but the time between the gestation is
actually half of that right so round
ones up to four it's about three to five
years yeah so my question is do they
actually give birth in between and
actually do eat two siblings
yeah so this is interesting is that
workaround and this is where what this
is where the accumulation so so to put
this in context for you
there's a hundred chimpanzees under
observation at Gombe and there's about
two or three hundred gorillas under
observation at care so key only half of
those are female and they're having a
baby every four to five years so it
takes a long time to accumulate these
metrics right and to be able to get
means and the tails of the distribution
and the in terms of that interesting
question about why doesn't the
interbirth interval and weaning line up
perfectly what's interesting is that we
have seen cases where where a mother
with a particularly short interbirth
interval will occasionally nurse that
older offspring once the baby arrives
but even then that's not more than a
year after that older offspring has
stopped but we also have these mothers
that have these interbirth interval that
are six or so years and that kid keeps
nursing and occasionally this is what's
interesting she does get pregnant and
give birth to another baby who doesn't
make it and that older kid never stops
never stops goes I like I would say goes
right back to the nipple but literally
never stops it's nursing right up until
birth and then if the baby dies early
then keeps nursing so it's all those
kind of interesting variability that we
just don't have a handle on and that's
what we're we're trying to get at here
but but the moment I know I should say
it's different across different
chimpanzee communities so different
chimpanzee communities studied in
different places in Africa have slightly
different weaning ages and it seems to
be different according to well maybe
maybe it's different according to the
dominant status of the mother and but
the the mother would nurse both
like on a one-off thing like not not
consistent it's just that the older
sibling would kind of hop back on for a
little bit
how much maybe it'd be great if you
could tell us a little bit about what
it's like on site because are all the
observations firsthand are there are
there cameras around what's what's
what's the nature what's the size what's
the nature of this condition so when you
are this is how it works at Gombe it's a
little bit different at Kara Sookie and
Rwanda because they're they have more
limited time with the gorillas but what
I do when I'm a call me is that I wake
up very early in the morning we know
where the chimps have slept the night
before because they actually build a
night nest in the trees and if you
follow them until late in the day when
they build that nest you're like great
that's where he'll be at 6:00 a.m.
tomorrow so you wake up so that you're
with them at 6:00 a.m.
and what our on-site researchers do is
they follow a single kind of focal
individual all day from the time they
get up till the time they go to bed and
they're taking a series of consistent
data every 15 minutes but then taking
longhand data throughout the day about
interesting things like mating and
grooming and fighting and all that kind
of stuff so you're on foot in the
morning a chimp comes down from the tree
wake up time is a really good time to
collect fecal samples by the way just
makes sense if you think about it right
so you get there in the morning collect
all your samples then you're with the
chimps all day and you're following them
at a distance of about 7 meters that's
what we consider kind of a safe distance
for them and for us they break it often
because you're either in their way or
they're curious so like me to the the
fourth row and you're just you're with
them and recording everything they do
all day now we have several teams out we
have a team that's that's focused on the
adults and we also have a specific team
focused on mothers and kids as part of
this grant so there's gonna be multiple
teams out in the day following
individual chimpanzees around
documenting their behavior where they go
what they eat collecting samples all day
and that has been going on essentially
unchanged since 1966
and you and you're based in Pennsylvania
but you're out there how many I'm out
there once a year
uh-huh when I was a student I could go
more but then I invested in my own
offspring it all went downhill from
there these expensive children oh we've
got another question in the back there
I'm interested in childbirth no could
you talk a little bit about it sociology
where the mother goes anything about
that I mean so just make sure you're
holding it close so we can hear you
childbirth anything about how many
individuals are around when the child is
when the infant is born first treatments
pain yeah so the question for if you
guys couldn't hear it was about
childbirth and the act of childbirth and
and how that happens in apes and in
chimpanzees interestingly enough a
colleague of mine is finalizing a paper
and analysis of that right now but it's
highly variable so that's the important
thing to point out about chimpanzees is
that they are extremely aggressive
within their own community and
infanticide is a real risk from from
strangers chimpanzees but also from
chimpanzees in your community both males
and females so a newborn baby is
incredibly vulnerable its mother is
subject to infanticidal attacks and so
because of that what often happens is
that mom goes on a bit of a maternity
leave and wants to be by herself when
she gives birth to that baby now we of
course have outliers we have a very had
she's passed away now a very dominant
female named Fifi who had more babies
than anybody else she's the one in that
picture
touching Jane I mean she's kind of the
best documented animal I think on the
planet very comfortable in her community
and also with humans and she would give
birth like right in front of tourists
like she's just like you know her her
sons were always alpha male like she
wasn't worried about this infant
I don't think Rockstar behavior yeah but
typically there is a real maternity
leave and we don't know much about it
because if they decide to be where we
can't find them we can't find them so I
can't answer your question really well
because we don't get to see it very much
how distinctive are these between
different great apes are these wildly
different and and some of the things
we're talking about here as far as
weaning and and and childbirth but they
tend to be parallel in in orangutans are
in well aracely's are a little bit weird
and the great apes because they're moat
they're pretty solitary and ninety
percent arboreal so we don't see a lot
of what happens with the Rings because
it happens way up in the trees and you
only see one Arang at a time whereas I'm
typically seeing about 1015 chimps at a
time and gorillas what typically happens
is that the researchers of the the
trackers show up and there's a new baby
and it was born overnight but what
happens with us for chimpanzees is that
we well now we know a female is pregnant
because human pregnancy tests work on
them and you just you just have to be
standing in either the right place or
wrong place at the right time to get a
urine sample depending on how you look
at it morning also good for that so we
knit we typically know now when they're
pregnant and and then if we don't see
them for a while it's the assumption is
that they're either going to come back
not pregnant and maybe we'll have a baby
there's another one back there question
yeah I had a question um you mentioned
that you weren't sure what the function
of the the suckling was later later in
the later years I have a 13 year old who
still likes to have his back scratched
right yeah how much cuddling do these
gorillas do besides you know the nursing
is that is that the primary way that
they bond with the youth or is there a
lot of physical interaction no there's a
ton there's a that's a really good point
there's a ton of cuddling I mean there's
a ton of contact in fact a baby ape is
is in contact with it's with its mother
a hundred percent of the time throughout
most of the first year but then what
apes switch to as opposed to just
cuddling is grooming and so grooming is
is a very validated metric of social
affiliation and social bonding so
mothers spend a ton of time grooming
their kids kids don't groom their
parents so much anybody who's a parent
wasn't surprised about that but also
it's it also is a good proxy for us for
adult friendships as well so we actually
use grooming metrics to understand which
chimpanzees are friends so the cuddling
the the function how that looks and Apes
is this grooming behavior and there's
intensive grooming between moms and kids
all the time not so much between dads
and kids and chimps because like I said
it's a promiscuous mating system and as
far as we know dads don't know which kid
or if that kid is there's one more from
the audience but let me ask you what's
the relationship between the park and
the all this research you're doing with
conservation and or with the anti
poaching things or so there's a lot of
things I've is it going on there too
right so I should say that neither of
those populations of apes would be alive
today without the research
I mean if Jane and Diane hadn't been
those populations of apes would be gone
and that's only from 60 years that the
behavioral research really put those
parks on the map and are those
populations stable growing what's the
mountain gorilla population is actually
growing the problem is their habitat is
not so that starts to run into a little
bit a problem because they live at the
top of these volcanoes and volcanoes
don't go any higher so so the the Fauci
Fund is working on that both the the
Jane Goodall Institute and the Fauci
Fund have incredibly positive working
relationships with the parks they're
separate entities the parks management
is a is a country organization and the
research organizations or NGOs but in
both cases with the Jane Goodall
Institute in the Dian Fossey fund
there's heavy collaboration in terms of
anti poaching conservation a lot of kind
of cross-pollination between the
behavioral research and how that impacts
kind of a conservation direction of the
parks yeah and and you see as you sort
of touched on briefly but the the in
country X
Bertie's is a part of consuming that
effort as well so I think one of the
things that is important and has been a
real focus at least for the Gombe
researchers which I can speak to you
more directly over the last decade is
that the future of this research should
lie in the Tanzanian people that live in
that country who whose legacy is those
those chimps so when I showed the
picture of Jane's legacy there's a whole
bunch of you know white faces in the
middle of this conference but there's a
whole bunch of Tanzanian faces that were
highlighted in the edges and that's you
know investing in Tanzania and phd's
Tanzania and veterinarians and making
sure that our on-site staff is run by
Tanzanians and investing in their
investment in conservation and behaviour
in their country and both the Jane
Goodall Institute and the Dian Fossey
fund who I don't work for by the way so
it's not much at commercial they've both
invested heavily in building that local
expertise yeah do you another there we
go hi thank you great talk
so I had one question so it seems like
we think a lot about the nutritional
relationship so to what extent and what
hypotheses do you have about what
they're learning behaviorally during
that time so maybe they're not
necessarily there for purely the goodies
mm-hmm what what can we tell that
they're learning from their mother well
certainly I mean just being in proximity
to mom is a great source of comfort so
if I mean some of you that have had kids
might have dealt with this but like
whenever there's a ruckus in the group
like a kid runs immediately to her mom
and if it's a young enough kid they go
immediately to the nipple and it's like
you were just eating I mean come on like
that that is clearly a comfort thing so
that proximity to mom is a source of
comfort
obviously suckling when an infant is
distressed is a source of comfort in
terms of the the learning though
remember that this is balanced by the
fact that mom is so
to start at some point investing in that
next offspring right so weaning if it's
at the appropriate time is beneficial to
the mom and so the mom and kid are in
conflict about when that weaning should
occur so the kid doesn't need I mean
essentially the kid doesn't need to be
attached to the nipple to learn stuff
right and the mom is motivated to get
the kid off the nipple and invest in the
next offspring so that learning doesn't
have to occur attached and to kind of
wrap things up and kind of go back to
this pretty unique relationship you have
with another researcher that you're
there's a hand didn't you tell me but
but I think it's pretty unusual to have
this kind of handoff I mean it's a it's
not a typical subject maybe but I'm
curious both what was something about
what that transition was like of coming
in with with a body of work that was
already there maybe some of which was a
little untraditional or used different
methods then might be the technological
standard today what have you and then
also as you think about your experience
with that what are you thinking about as
far as as it goes forward from you and
and both in terms of the the work that
you're doing there at the park but but
other research and in the community
would what are you thinking about how to
continue that knowledge into the future
yeah so so what's great about Jane is
that you know she's in regular contact
with the researchers that are they were
working in Gombe she's amazing with you
know when you I see her about once a
year and you know and she's like okay
come by the house and tell me what your
the house I call me come by the house
tell me what you're up to I want to hear
what's going on I'm like oh I'm just
doing this I'm just doing this and she's
always super excited and she'll always
actually beyond being excited to be like
you know there was this time and it's
something that she's pulling out of the
dark reaches that's not necessarily
something I would have known to go
looking for the archives that I can then
add to the story so despite the fact
that she's like you know dame of the
British Empire
world peace all the stuff she is
she's still very engaged and supportive
of the researchers that are continuing
her work which is awesome the I think
the what I hope kind of the future is is
that we really empower the that you know
the Tanzanian researchers that we've
developed to have this be a real
training ground in place for Tanzania
and behavioral scientists in Tanzania
and x8 experts I mean of course there's
always gonna be expats working there but
I mean it really should be the balance
should be shifting to more local
scientists I think and so the projects
that I've been involved with always have
kind of a local counterpart and lastly
the work you shared with us tonight is
pretty much brand new right to stuff
like recently 10 o'clock this morning
no not 10 o'clock this morning no a
couple months ago and we submitted the
grant but so just just tell us briefly
where does that seem to be headed where
is it at in the process where is that
seem to be headed and so luckily we have
60 years of behavioural data the
analysis of that weaning time and some
of the variation is something I've been
working on this year while I'm at
Stanford so that's from a publication
standpoint will be submitted in the next
couple months
the chimps continue to poop and we
continue to pick it up so we have we
have a bio Bank of I'm not kidding 3,000
samples that are getting ready to be
exported and shipped to the US for
analysis and in fact on our road trip
home from California back to
Pennsylvania I have to swing by
Minneapolis to pick up some chimp teeth
to get it to DC for the analysis there
so everything's kind of coming together
yeah
well that's that's all we have time for
on stage but you're going to stick
around for a little bit we hope you'll
stick around come up ask questions and
keep this conversation going amongst
yourselves as well we have a little
thank-you gift as we do for all of our
speakers along now challenge
to remind you to seize the millennium I
got it thank you guys for your pen dad's
a question for being here our speaker
tonight thanks everyone
[Music]